hello we're glad you've joined us for
this live webinar osteo sarcoma research
presented by Luke Patterson I'm Alexis
Krause of laberd's and I'll be
moderating this session today's
educational web seminar is presented by
laberd's and brought to you by thermo
Fisher Scientific for more information
on our sponsor please visit thermo
Fisher comm now let's get started you
can submit questions to the speaker
during the presentation while they're
fresh in your mind to do so simply type
them into the drop down box located on
the far left your screen labeled ask a
question and click on the send button
well answer as many questions as we have
time for at the end of the presentation
if you experience technical problems
seeing or hearing the presentation just
click on the support tab found at the
top-right of the presentation window or
report your problem by typing it into
the ask a question box located on the
far left ear screen this is an
educational webinar and thus offers free
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window and follow the
process of obtaining your credits I now
present today's speaker Luke Tattersall
postdoctoral research associate the
university of sheffield medical school
for a complete biography on our speaker
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen Luke you may now
begin your presentation
thank you for the introduction and for
inviting me to present this webinar if
you don't follow me already please see
my Twitter which is at dr. L taught us
all 24 or Instagram at Luke's lab Bible
the work carried out in our lab has been
funded by the bone cancer research trust
and Hannah's Wilbury wonder pony so I
recommend that you visit their website
also so to start with
different types of bone cancer primary
bone cancer originates in the bone where
a secondary bone cancer spreads to the
bone from other locations such as a
breast cancer a prostate cancer or a
lung cancer they then travel in the
blood or the lymphatic system and
colonize the bone where they then form a
new tumor in this presentation I will be
focusing on osteosarcoma which is a type
of primary bone cancer so primary bone
cancer then is split into different
subtypes including osteosarcoma Ewing
sarcoma chondrosarcoma and cor DOMA
which account for approximately
eighty-five percent of all cases there
are also some rarer subtypes such as
spindle cell sarcoma of the bone
adamantine oma angiosarcoma and giant
cell tumor of the bone osteosarcoma is
the most common type primary bone cancer
and is of mesenchymal origin it occurs
as a cancer of the osteoblasts or of
their precursor cells these cells are
responsible for the production of new
bone during normal skeletal remodelling
osteosarcoma commonly occurs in the
limbs specifically in the metathesis
reading of the bone this is the area of
the bone containing all the periphery
themselves osteosarcoma can actually
occur in any bone of the body however
common regions such as around the knee
i've highlighted on the slide you can
also see an osteosarcoma tumor
originating in the bone and where it's
invading into the surrounding tissue so
osteosarcoma vamp is considered a rare
disease and it was a rate of one to five
people per million per year
males are slightly affected more than
females and it most commonly affects
young people between the age of 10 to 25
but it has a peak age of incidence at 18
there is however a second peak of
incidence in people over 50 well this
can be due to other bone conditions for
example such as Paget's disease the
five-year survival rate frosty or
sarcoma is around 60 to 70%
but this reduces to 20 to 30 percent
with metastasis and the most common
place that metastasis is found in
osteosarcoma is in the lungs an
important point is that osteosarcoma
survival statistics remain the same for
a number of decades so osteo sarcoma
them presents with a number of symptoms
including bone pain tenderness or a lump
or swelling problems with mobility a
bone fracture tiredness and weight loss
muscle loss easy bruising or an
unexplained limp and actually pain
killers will not really help with the
pain which can come become worse at
night because the disease is quite rare
GPS don't really come across it in their
career and some of the symptoms that
they can see they can attribute to grow
in pains or traumas such as for example
or sporting act in fact the sporting
injury leading to a misdiagnosis and
then this can then delay how quickly
they get treated so when diagnosing
osteosarcoma although imaging techniques
such as x-rays CT scans and MRI scans
are used to aid the diagnosis for
natural definitive osteosarcoma
diagnosis biopsy is required but with
the cells then being examined by an
experienced pathologist
so because osteosarcoma so commonly
occurs in the limb amputation with the
traditional treatment an alternative is
where surgeon can do rotation plastic
this is where they take a portion of the
limb remove it and they move the ankle
joint up and reattach it at the knee
backwards so this enabled the ankle
joint to become a functional knee joint
meaning that a has increased function in
with the limb when the prosthetic is
attached so this increases mobility for
the patient and is given to for example
younger patients that want to still
remain active so additionally to this
limb Salvage techniques can be used in
combination with neoadjuvant an adjuvant
chemotherapy which is used to initialize
from tumor size before surgery and then
to kill any remaining selves after
surgery the chemotherapy prosti of
sarcoma consists of methotrexate
doxorubicin cisplatin and i phosphor
might additionally meet pact has also
been recently approved for treatment of
osteosarcoma and is used for patients
with Nam metastatic osteosarcoma
but again importantly the standard
treatment for osteosarcoma hasn't
changed for around 30 years since the
introduction of chemotherapy so just to
carry on with the treatments limb
Salvage surgery can be done in a number
of ways it can be done by a autologous
bone graft with this is where healthy
bone is taken from different part of the
patient's body to replace the damaged
part or you can have an allograft which
is used with the bone from someone else
you can also remove the bone and
irradiate it and put it back into the
patient however in osteosarcoma the
majority of cases the bone is replaced
with a metal implant made specific lifts
for the patient however this may then
need to be adjusted in the future if the
patient is still young unless still
growing so moving on to the research
that we do so we do research
in vitro to start with so this is using
cell lines in the lab were originally
from patients but then were immortalized
so we can use them over and over so
common human osteosarcoma cell lines
include te 85 l n ng house say us to a
143 be the th of fives are immature
osteoblasts say ah stews and mature
osteoblasts m n ng house is a derivative
that the th v ly which was treated with
lemon ng a carcinogen and is an
osteogenic and lobster with excel why
the 143 B is again a derivative of the
TE 85 and it's a highly aggressive
highly osteo lytic and highly metastatic
spell line common mouth cell lines
include the dunce ly and it's derivative
Ln ak7 and it's derivative k7m - and the
way these derivatives are produced is
they will inject the cells into the
mouse let them testifies to the lungs
and then collect those and keep
repackaging them into the mouse and keep
doing that over and over that's why Ln a
is called LMH it took 8 times do this
until you establish this new metastatic
derivative of those cell lines a final
Mouse cell line that's used is called
mus J and in addition to this there are
also rat and canine cell lines that are
available such as um r106 which was from
an experimental rap and d 17 which was
isolated from a poodle because dogs can
be susceptible for osteosarcoma as well
so they can actually provide a clinical
model also so tells you like this can be
used for a number of different
experiments that we use that we do in
the lab so we look for example at the
cell growth over a number of days we
look at their migration invasion
adhesion or their response to drug
treatments and specifically in our lab
we use human cells because they're more
representative than animal cells and
they are human specific proteins that we
want to target
they're also relatively cheap they're
easily available I don't have any
ethical considerations however on the
other hand if you were to then put issue
themselves in a mouth you have to be a
mutant mice which is immunocompromised
so the cells aren't rejected by the
house so obviously you're not taking
into consideration your immune response
there so that's a disadvantage of that
so with these cells we perform in vivo
studies and the way we do it in our lab
is we perform a peritoneal injection of
the cells into the mouse so missions
where I take the mouse I Anissa ties it
and with the needle to inject the cell
where scratch the surface of the bone to
ensure that the periosteum is activated
and that the cells are in injected into
a relevant location so because of this
as we're analyzing the bone it's
important to ensure that the power civil
injection doesn't actually damage the
bone so to do this what we did is we
scratched the bone and didn't inject any
cells we then confirmed that there was
no difference when view in the bone or
won't analyzing this by micro CT so we
could then analyze our important bone
volume characteristics without with
knowing that that wasn't caused by our
injection method so in us - so here is
the mice where they are formed
osteosarcoma tumors on slides and you
can see that they have these large
osteosarcoma tumors coming from the bone
which become palpable after nine days
you can actually start treatment on them
as soon as you inject them or you can
wait until tumors formed and then give a
treatment we also give chemotherapy as a
positive control to compare
so we then do a analysis of the bone
using micro CT so due to the tumor being
osteoblastic new bone is still being
produced called ectopic bone
so remember osteoblasts build bone
normal bone remodeling and now they
become cancerous but doesn't stop them
doing that function they will still
produce a bone so this is typically seen
in patients and we see it in our app and
our mouse models this increase in bone
volume can be quantified
but using micro CT is increased when
compared to its corresponding right leg
which hasn't been injected so using this
we can then look to see if any
treatments that we've been given to the
mice have any effect on reducing this so
in addition to this we further do
analysis of the primary tumor so when we
collect the mouse legs from them we
actually leave all the surrounding
tissue around them because the entire
tumor is half-and-half essentially with
this with the bone and the surrounding
tissue so by taking all of it you you
can see the entire tumor and then you
can section this and perform a different
experiments whichever you want so we do
things like histology which is performed
to view the cell characteristics for
example it's osteoid production we do
trap staining which is used to quantify
off the across at the tumor bone
interface so what I mean by this is
where the tumor meets the bone and it
can be upregulated or downregulated and
we're able to measure this we can also
do immunise the chemistry which is
performed to detect different markers
such as ki-67 which is expressed by
proliferating cells so then we can see
if our treatments are increasing our
decrease in this or we can use an X in v
which is a marker that cells express
when they undergoing sole death so we
can see if your treatments are killing
the cells so this gives a lot of
information man about this and we we
perform these immunise to chemistry
experiments
finally as the lungs of the most common
sight for osteosarcoma metastasis we
take these from the mice and we check
themselves to do this we see really
section the lungs all the way through so
that we're taking multiple slides at
multiple different points of the lungs
and then checking all of them for
osteosarcoma metastasis and we doing
that just so that we don't miss any of
the small osteosarcoma cells but might
be residing that in the lung gun and
these can be again stained and examined
and we can see if our treatments rather
than any effects are a charcoal
Justices or not so to conclude the
presentation has given an overview of
osteosarcoma primary bone cancer and an
insight into osteosarcoma research both
in vitro and in vivo which we perform in
the lab so I finally just like to
acknowledge Michael embodies the bone
cancer research just and Hannah's will
be wonderfully the University of
Sheffield Medical School my supervisors
professor Allison Gartland and dr.
Shelley Olsen all the lab members
including box challenge are mr. Darrin
lab and Miss Jen down thank you and now
I'm open for any questions thanks
you
Thank You Luke for your presentation a
quick reminder for our audience on how
to submit questions just click on the
ask a question box located on the far
left your screen and we'll answer as
many of your questions we have time for
so let's get started
our first question other than the lung
where else does osteosarcoma metastasize
so the as I said the the most common
places the lungs thought the the second
most common place all of them along is
the bone and what can actually happen is
some in some instances with these
osteosarcoma tumors they will spread but
still colonize the same bone and this is
called skips metastasis so it's where a
part of the tumor breaks away from the
bone actually colonizers the same bone
that is coming from but it can actually
you know spread to any bone other than
that it also spread to the lymph nodes
and in rare cases it can spread to the
brain the liver or the kidneys now look
what is GP
what is sorry what ah what is G p GP
general practitioner I think that would
be my guess value I guess you all right
let's switch to our next question do you
have any information on osteosarcoma of
the jawbone or is this strictly a course
on long bone sarcomas
so austere sarcoma the jaw is very rare
so it's not something I'm too familiar
with but if the most common places is
the limbs around 80% so it does occur in
my jaw and it has similar clinical
characteristics as any other
osteosarcoma but it is such a rare rare
rare thing to happen it's not something
you come across too often
now
cats are known for not having much of
osteosarcoma do you have a plan to
analyze the biology and cat for
osteosarcoma
I haven't any plans to do that now and
it's common in large dogs as well and
they are used as clinical models for
osteosarcoma as well
all right loop so our next question is I
miss what happens to bone itself as a
result of bone sarcoma development is
ectopic bone growth a source of pain yes
the most common symptoms of osteosarcoma
it yeah growth this x-bow around benign
yes that's it
one thing sir
you
do you have any idea why the clinical
trials have been failing for
osteosarcoma drugs
first book the problem with osteosarcoma
is it doesn't actually have one known
cause it has a lot of different
characteristics in different people so
it's what with very heterogeneous
disease so that means that not
necessarily one thing will work for you
know everyone whereas you know you're
trying to develop drugs or work for as a
general store against osteosarcoma and a
group such advisor disease essentially
the last you know a big problem and also
you you know the standard treatments
also become chemo resistance as well so
yeah you know it's developing like all
the things as well but yes because it's
such a diverse disease that a lot of
clinical trials have had problems
we are getting some great questions
right now so let's continue with our
next one look do you think there is a
correlation between survival rate and no
change in current treatment yeah
definitely definitely ya know no
treatments are coming coming through so
obviously yeah that's affected your your
survival rate amazed they stayed
constant
now what other invivo injections are
there other than the pair tibial one so
what some of my boots do is they do an
interosseous injection where what they
will do is they will direct straight
into the bone so into the bone marrow
and the cells will you know start going
from there we we don't do that because
you know that would sort of damage all
your bone architectural that's one of
the things we want to analyze all the
things that I use are some titanius
injections so that's just under the skin
so it's not necessarily the bone
microenvironment there and in metastatic
osteosarcoma to measure that what we'll
do is inject into the tail vein of the
mouse and then just measure that where
the cells are spreading to so that and
how long you know it takes to then get
to the lungs and and compare that like
for example with the treatment or
without etc so now I do with a the other
technique now our next question is going
to be a two-part question what is your
general practice getting the DNA RNA
from the bone tissue and the second part
is do you have to decalcify the tissue
which can lead to DNA RNA degradation
yes when we do the analysis on the the
mouse bone here we key calcify the
tissue yet so you know it's not
something that we can account for that
yeah we you know when you're doing your
immune system Emma sure you essentially
cutting into the bone and obviously that
would be with the calcium it'll be too
too hard and we'll be able to cut
through it so yeah we do decalcify them
in able to section the bones so yeah and
then you can extract a DNA and RNA from
cell lines that's generally what we're
I've used any from previously
now our next question is there any
genetic predisposition for osteosarcoma
so there are instances where in
osteosarcoma there are there are links
to the diseases so for example there's a
link between osteosarcoma and
retinoblastoma so where people have
these hereditary cancers in throat
although the Rena West over itself the
secondary highest one is osteosarcoma
and if you have a retinoblastoma cancer
though you're actually around like
something like 500 times more likely to
get an osteosarcoma tumors and it's the
same with literal many disease which is
a disease that affects here p53 function
so again that's that's another one
that's linked to osteosarcoma yes so
there are a few yeah
now dude the bone cells metastasized
both by the lymphatic system and blood
yeah they do yeah so you could you know
there's there are some researchers that
try and look at circulating tumor cells
from the blood as well so for example
they'll collect the blood of the mice
and the capacity through a machine that
will try and detect those circulating
tumor cells and you know that can may be
potentially one day aid you know a
diagnosis
now look how many cells do you inject in
vivo so when we're doing it we generally
tend to use around 250,000 to 500,000
and the reason why that's actually quite
low from from a cell call to flash you
can actually have millions of cells but
when when the animal is there in the
bone microenvironment do grow really
quick and then you're actually limited
on the size of the tumor in the mouse
and if you want to get metastases you
need to leave them in there for so long
for that to start developing so the
problem is sometimes that you can have a
really large primary tumor and then eat
the mice can start to begin to limp and
be in discomfort and then we're not
allowed to leave them that long but like
I regulated by law so we have to take
that into consideration so we generally
start off with a lower amount of cells
in order to try and extend our length of
treatment that we can then give to the
mice that's which quite quite low there
are papers you know that have gone
higher than that before for for example
for around you know a million cells in
mice but we generally use lower now do
you use only imaging or do you analyze
the bone histo histo logically yeah we
analyze the bone histologically and from
from the mice yes so we will do things
like you know if a woman
I played section in sections of the bone
doing munis to chemistry and yes not
just imaging we do do a range of
different techniques
you
now Luke our next question do you use
patient osteosarcoma samples so with
patient osteosarcoma samples because
it's so rare it's they are quite hard to
get hold of and it can take years in
order for a large cohort of osteosarcoma
samples so we we in the future are
aiming to but we haven't been been able
to at the moment but we are hoping to
yeah and generally when you speak to
osteosarcoma patients from from my
experience they do generally want to
want their osteosarcoma tissue to be
used for research they generally quite
you know helpful with that so it's just
a case of actually getting that tissue
and then getting it to his researches
and in the UK the bone cancer research
that they funded my PhD and they're
they're doing a big sort of
infrastructure thing where what they're
doing is trying to standardize like the
procedure between different bone bone
research centers so that it becomes more
easier to enable access to patient
sample yes so for researchers like me to
use that tissue they're trying to make
it more available
now look does injecting BMP antagonists
such as noggin would be used would that
be useful to stop bone growth
I shall allow that or not I'm taking
this for them but I'm familiar with to
be honest
well let's go to our next question what
is the relationship between packets
disease in osteosarcoma
so Paget's disease is a disease of the
bone as well and it generally occurs in
more older people and it's very
condition involving cellular remodeling
and deformity and it's where basically
they have dysregulated bone remodeling
so specifically they have excess bone
breakdown and some subsequently they
have disorganized
new bone formation and it like so
generally that's in older people and you
know there's no cure for that and that
is sort of been described as a
predisposition for for osteosarcoma
patients but yeah it's generally
osteosarcoma is generally second
secondary to luck so lucre
our next question has a couple parts to
it so we'll start with the first one
which benign tumors lead to ours osteo
sarcoma
I'm so generally all osteosarcoma is a
considered high-grade I'm not sure which
ones actually need to osteo sarcoma viz
there's a lot of different subsets that
are benign tumors that are separate from
osteosarcoma and I don't think they I'm
not sure about how they they do that
and now the second and third part are is
do you work with Ja osteosarcoma and is
it the same cell line for jaw and long
bone osteosarcoma so good question so
the cell lines that I use were
originally isolated from patients so
they were from you know an osteosarcoma
of the tibia or the femur
I I haven't used my cell lines us from a
osteosarcoma from the jaw now but it
would be good you know if that was
available to look at that and you know
see what the differences were but it's
not something I really come across and
again it is such a rare disease
osteosarcoma the jaw it's you know
osteosarcoma was rare anyway there's a
few hundred cases in the UK so you know
even get going away from that you know -
it's an even rarer one it's not
something we've really come across
here's a piggyback question off one that
we had before you may get disease as
associated with osteosarcoma can you
tell me a little bit more about it as a
about Paget's disease
yes Paget's disease
so I'm not too sure I know how
osteosarcoma mainly it's you know it's
cheating with bisphosphonates Australian
increase the the bone you know it's the
second most common metabolic disorder
disorder after osteoporosis and you know
there it's rare in people that are
younger it's more in all the people like
I said earlier you can either put it
kind of a family history but you know I
don't know too much about Paget disease
only that it can be a predisposition
prostate sarcoma
you
now our next question is increased
alkaline fossil phosphatase associated
to osteosarcoma
so alkaline phosphatase is a marker of
bone growth so because obviously the
cancer for osteosarcoma is an osteopath
are building the bone and yeah you can
get increased our client roster aphasia
now are those osteosarcoma cell lines
Feherty p53 mutations and are there any
other mutations known for them so could
you keep up oh absolutely quite sure I
think white spatula I though no problem
are those osteosarcoma cell lines there
tp53 mutations and are there any other
mutations known for them so I'm not I'm
not sure about within the cell line
which mutations they have got they've
been chemically transformed in the lab
so they will have a lot of different
things wrong with them there's you know
like for example hostiles they've been
fused with MN ng which is a carcinogen
which makes them more aggressive so that
will you know that will affect load the
genes of the different cell lines to be
honest so there's a lot of a lot of
different things but the different
here's another question for you Luke
what do you think needs to be done for
treatment so what do I think needs to be
done in terms of progressing the
treatment we can actually if you if you
would like we can have her we can have
you put in another question to clarify
to clarify that question of what do you
think needs to be done for treatment and
yet we can yeah so we'll wait for her
we'll wait for their answer other
questions
okay so risk factors are there for
osteosarcoma okay so as I mentioned
oxytocin was another known cause there
are some things that are linked to
osteosarcoma so but it's very general
thing so for example younger people it
affects it generally osteosarcoma
patients are taller than average because
there's a link there between you know
the rapid bone growth and having growth
spurts males again slightly all the
females you know that could be because
they're going larger their bones are
growing more and you know that's leading
to problems there
there is instances where if you've had a
different cancer and they treated you
with radiation for that that can
predispose for osteosarcoma as well so
yes so that could be considered a risk
factor and then again some of the
genetic conditions that we I mentioned
daily for example retinoblastoma defect
or little many syndromes or Paget's
disease you know that sort of things so
there are some risk factors yet for
osteosarcoma but you know there is no
known cause
now which osteosarcoma cell line is the
most metastatic so the human cells
the osteosarcoma the cell lines the 143
B cells are the most metastatic models
using the human cells so if you put them
into my Stovall you know they were for
metastasis pretty much in you know if
you put me in ten my stick for
metastasis in ten much so they're really
you know Matt static in terms of mice
Mouse cell lines that you can use the
LMA is a woman metastatic very innate
max a highly metastatic osteosarcoma
mouth so line and again k7m to is
another one that's highly mass Dyke as
well that's another mouse one but that
is so they would be you know the one
human feels too much a divot the ones
that are the most mistake
okay look so our next question I see ja
osteosarcoma how close are we to a
targeted therapy for osteosarcoma and
what is the general path of current
research so I'm not sure how close we
are for targeted therapy for
osteosarcoma the I'm not sure what
entire research is out there the
research that I'm doing is looking at
for example developing ways of
overcoming chemo resistance so you know
it's upsetting some subsets of patients
you know they will become they will have
instances where the teen therapy will
start working we're trying to find out
why why that is what differences in
themselves as to why that might occur
and we're doing screening processes to
develop new drugs against that at the
moment so that's why we're we're go
we're going with with our research at
the moment and the way that we do that
is we'll take the cells given
chemotherapy which will kill off a lot
of themselves
let the sub population grow back keep
giving them chemotherapy let them go
back like that again and again until
eventually Kings earth is not having any
effects and then you'll have your
kenosis and cell line so for all of the
minutes more so overcoming that and
developing new things that will come out
so that's where our research is is going
on the minute
we have had a great question Q&A session
today but we do only have time for one
more so Luke we'll finish with this one
okay do you do you inject into both my
flakes in vivo so the what we do is if I
was comparing two different mices then
for example the they might may be
different sizes so to compare one mice
to the other match wouldn't be accurate
so what we do first is we only inject in
wrong leg and then we can essentially
normalize that value to its
contralateral leg so we only injecting
one but compare it to the other leg has
not been injected because that is
essentially a normal bone in in that leg
there so if you're looking at bone
volumes we can normalize it to the other
bone and see if there's an increase or
decrease and you know with that copied
bone you will generally see you know an
increase and then once that's been
normalized you can then compare you you
different mice so yes there's only only
one mouth like that we inject into
Thank You Luke do you have any final
comments for our audience thanks thank
you for listening to my presentation and
for asking really lots of great
questions
thank you again Luke for your time today
and for your important research we'd
also like to elaborate and you can't our
sponsor Thermo Fisher Scientific for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions questions we
did not have time for today and those
submitted during on-demand period will
be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information that you provided at
the time of registration this webcast
can be viewed on-demand through August
of 2019 leverage will alert you via
email when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time
goodbye
you